[Applaus] [Musik] [Applaus] [Musik] [Applaus]
lassen Sie das bitte so so jetzt haben wir
verhaftet gell ich bin's doch nur für unseren
Clan Kriminalität ja und was spiele ich den
Clan oder die Kriminalität hier du spielst den
Chef [Musik] fühlt man sich ganz anders mit so
einer Polizei auf einmal unbändige Lust mit aller
Härte des Rechtsstaats gegen klaren Kriminalität
auch Gesetzeshüter wegen dem Hut das ist nicht
lustig ja klar Kriminalität ist ein riesen Problem
was wir seit Jahren aus falscher Rücksichtnahme
irgendwie war niedliche man muss sich nur mal
die Statistiken der Landeskriminalämter
genauer anschauen im Herbst 2019 meldet
sich ein Polizeibeamter bei ihm er möchte anonym
bleiben wenn ein 15-jähriger Junge zum Beispiel
die Schule schwänzt und in einem Kiosk in
Hannover aus Langeweile einen Schokoriegel
klaut landet er weil er einen Nachnamen aus der
clan-tabelle trägt automatisch in der clanstadt
das ist eine riesen Problem
organisierter Kriminalität
so wie die spricht eindeutig klar ich
habe falsch hier parken das ist nur
Ordnungswidrigkeit ja das ist also ich
war zu spät dran habt ihr chillt nicht
gesehen das allerhöchsten Kriminalität
was entscheiden nicht Nachname Schulz
aha sehr guter fangen Herr Kollege
das ist ein Name aus der Clan Tabelle
sie sind Teil des schulds Schulz klagen doch
gibt da gar nichts dafür hören wir den Namen
Schulz hierzulande aber auffällig oft ja Schulz so
heißt noch Hinz und Kunze na na na Hinz und Kunz
heißen Hinz und Kunst weil sonst höchstens sie ja
nicht hins und Kunst sondern Schuldner aha jetzt
tut sie so als ob sie uns nicht verstehen würde
typisch Schulz klar bei dir treten wäre oder nicht
der Einstieg in den Clan ist in der Regel die
Geburt achso kriminell von ihr Geburt ja das ist
durch nein nein entschuldigen Sie das kann
nicht rassistisch sein weil dieser Satz schon
von einem Christdemokraten Innenminister in
Nordrhein-Westfalen der dieser Herbert also
ich sehe meine Familie eigentlich kaum man
braucht kaum Kontakte um zusammen zu arbeiten
ich arbeite nicht mit denen zusammen ja für
uns brauchen Sie nicht zusammenzuarbeiten
für organisiert die Kriminalität er ist nicht
die Definition von organisierter Kriminalität
wir definieren Zusammenarbeit ausschließlich
über den klaren relevanten Familiennamen genau
ja wenn man den hier eingibt dann tauchen
ganz schön viele Leute aus ihrem Plan auch
hier gleich der erste Schulz ehemaliger Anführer
einer kriminellen Bande das ist Martin Schulz
und die die SPD ist auch keine kriminelle
Bande das sehen wir hier anders
außerdem mit dem Fahrrad ja man muss nicht
verwandt sein um einen klaren anzugehören
es steht nicht die Definition von einem Clan
ja da gibt es auch noch ein aber Verdacht auf
Beihilfe zum Steuerbetrug in Milliarden Höhe
da steht Scholz Schulz und schalte sind zwei
völlig verschiedene Namen für die Statistik des
LKH sind das unterschiedliche Schreibweisen ein
und desselben Plans ja schauen Sie mal das
Problem ein falscher Nachname reicht um in
der LKA klar Statistik zu landen das gilt sogar
bei unterschiedlichen Schreibweisen ein Beispiel
der Name Miri davon gibt es unterschiedliche
Schreibweisen jede Variante schafft es in die
kleinstatistik so sind es gleich vier Fälle mehr
also ihr Scholz kommt aus Hamburg ja das sehen Sie
mal wie ihr planen sich inzwischen ausgebreitet
hat alle Mitgliedern der SPD für mich ergibt sich
da ein klares Muster ganz in Deutschland Zuordnung
nach Nachnamen Witz sein wie heißen sie eigentlich
machen
weiß aber nicht wie man den schreibt
ich habe falsche aber in falschem
Namen ja genau sehen Sie das ist
ein ganz klarer Hinweis auf Clan
kriminalitätsdelikte unsere Statistiken
erfassen natürlich weitaus mehr als nur
Falschparken ja in Niedersachsen z.B da sind
auch ganz andere Verbrechen mit dabei Rot über
die Straße gehen Verkauf von Getränken in Dosen
ohne Pfandsiegel Gangster rappen es ist ja noch
nicht meine Ordnungswidrigkeit das ist wurscht das
erfassen wir sicherheitshalber gleich mit ach so
also bei ihrer Zahlen erfasst und da wundert mich
gar nicht dass wir so eine hohe klangkriminalität
in Deutschland haben also stimmt ja gar nicht
so hoch wir haben sehr sie haben selber gesagt
wir haben viel zu wenig Kleinkriminalität ich
habe gesagt Plan Kriminalität umfasst in z.B in
Niedersachsen gerade mal 0,6 % der Kriminalität
in Berlin ist es noch weniger da sind nur 0,18
%. das heißt wir müssen unsere Bemühungen
deutlich erhöhen wir machen doch schon ne
Großeinsätze und Razzien in den Shisha Bars und
barbershops und was finden sie da so ja was wissen
was hier klingen und Tabak und verzollten Tabak
und manchmal sehr sehr verdorbenen Orangensaft
total nutzlos
außerdem
betreiben die Pleite gehen weil wir regelmäßig
kommen aber ansonsten ja und den nächsten drei
erschossen werden von Nazis war wie in
Hanau weil sie mit ihren total nutzlosen
Razzien die Shisha Bar stigmatisieren
Entschuldigung wir haben immer gesagt
warum machen Sie denn das ganze ja wegen der
Schlagzeilen die Leute müssen das Gefühl haben
wir tun was wir Ihre Sicherheit ja weil
die Leute Angst haben Kriminalität wegen
den ganzen Schlagzeilen die sie produzieren
durch ihre völlig nutzlosen Razzien da jetzt
jetzt macht doch lieber mal den richtigen Clans
Angst und nicht den Leuten ey ah da müsste man
an die Vermögen an Beweislastumkehr bei Geldern
unbekannter Herkunft Transparenzregister Bargeld
Obergrenzen bitte doch wir lassen uns doch
von einer klaren kriminellen nicht sagen was
klar Kriminalität ist ja selber nicht was Clan
Kriminalität ist richtig aber wir arbeiten dran
im neuen Koalitionsvertrag steht nämlich drin dass
bei der sogenannten klar Kriminalität da ist auf
eine definitorische Klärung hinzuarbeiten so ja
also sie gehen gegen irgendwas vor was sie selber
noch nicht mal definiert haben oder wie ja und
zwar mit Allah Härte so gebacken was auf geht's
vergessen
dann war das ja alles ganz umsonst
vielleicht wissen unsere Zuschauer
auch selbst wo sie abonnieren können
das jetzt noch zwei weitere Videos gucken
können stimmt unsere Zuschauer sind ja sehr klug